al final si algunos no se van quiero que
salgan de aquí y cerremos la puerta del
campo con 111 migrantes han sido
elegidos para irse del nuevo campo de
karate les han avisado hace solo algunas
horas mamá estoy verdaderamente feliz
porque voy a dejar este campo y me voy a
un lugar mejor no voy a vivir más en
esta miseria ni ver más incendios
estoy muy feliz de irme de aquí las voy
a echar de menos
gracias adiós
[Música]
pero la felicidad no es para todos los
miembros de algunas familias deben
separarse de mis hermanos se van con mis
padres al continente pero yo me tengo
que quedar aquí porque tengo un timbre
de rojo que me impide salir mi abuela se
queda para cuidarme
llamamos al jefe del campo y él decidió
que ali mohamed se quede aquí con su
abuela
qué más podemos hacer mi niño se queda
aquí
después de meses e incluso años les gos
estos migrantes son enviados a grecia
continental para vivir en unos
departamentos financiados por la unión
europea aunque no saben dónde van no
puede ser peor que moria al que todos
llaman el infierno no sé dónde vamos
quizás a salónica o creta en todo caso
espero que sea mejor que este campo
a bordo de este ferry estos 111
migrantes dejan atrás el infierno de
moria pero el camino para ellos está
lejos de terminar ahora entrarán por
primera vez en europa continental donde
deben retomar su demanda de asilo sólo
una vez resuelta podrán comenzar a
pensar en un futuro
[Música]